I miss his cute little soundtrack oh my
god
life is strange episode 2 just came out
I'm so excited I wasn't excited when I
when I started episode 2 but it blew me
away I mean now I start up so one it
really blew me away
I was really good I didn't think I have
that that teenage snow girl inside me
but I guess we all do one way or another
but yeah let's get this show on the road
baby I made the best decisions ever in
the last one so we're not even gonna
think about why what it did I saw some
reviews for episode 2 and they they look
pretty promising so that makes me even
more excited don't let the hype get to
your pants it's just a game yeah what
did either today fantastic that's that's
pretty cool let's play whoa what the
[ __ ] but he could be talking about
photographer have you done something
wrong talk to me hey Victoria what do
you want max I said bird pooping here at
blackwell do you understand what I'm
saying this is between you and me going
solo on Chloe
it makes perfect sense I'd see you today
welcome home max that's Rachel amber her
missing person posters are all over
blackwell
six months ago she just left Arcadia is
that a word without me something
happened to her wait is it grass tell me
the truth that's an order
I didn't black out I had another vision
the town is going to get wiped out by a
tornado
max tell me everything okay
I remember them why they recap in I'm
I'm really curious what's gonna happen I
really really loved the soundtrack of
this of this one it just makes such a
difference I don't know
I can only snooze so I guess I'm gonna
do that can't go back in time and sleep
some more
I mean she could do that right say what
the music does to me
it's not good she's been studying about
Taemin traveling
[Music]
Oh something
nearly strange evening
especially sleeping without a cover who
does that I like her she should though
[Music]
spend a lot of frame rain I don't know
what's everything
[Music]
she sleeps with music on
oh she's relaxing I get it now he was so
wrecked after staying up all night
I could use my rewind to catch a few
more Z's but yeah maybe I better save my
strings
[Music]
oh thanks Iike that em [ __ ] bottle in
front of it
[Music]
in mid sound being super how is a child
I need a shower
son I'm gonna make cut here all right
game should look better for you now and
run smoother so let's take a shower I
[Music]
have a got a text message
you dare max like I said all this for
you smiley face smiley face
now emoji me me a diner for I'll be
there do not be late or I'll know it's
not on your side our time is on design
don't get high like in my room
hahaha on my way you're evil 40 minutes
or else who is evil why am i evil
[ __ ] talking about why she an emoji
hate it huh how can you hate on emojis
with all this crazy [ __ ] I better not
leave without my shower supplies No
alright cuz I know where they are
oh they're here take them know that I
wonder I felt everywhere I'll watch
again that is a pretty badass watch I
got it gotta energy take them thank you
okay max let's hit the showers now
finally don't forget I need those papers
before tonight
like now thanks sherry yeah of course
Victoria
I'll get the taxi papers to his
afternoon being considerate Dennett Sam
Oh what do you dad what did that I'm
sorry Becky stitch kiss you're ugly
don't worry about it what's going on in
here hmm
hey how's it going girl Mandy's this
school really seems like hard work
everyone is so busy what's happening
Dana everything cool between you and
Juliet oh yeah thanks again for
releasing me from her captivity oh yeah
it's the way the best and biggest news
of the day is that Trevor asked me to
the Halloween shindig that's awesome
Dana at least we're showing our faces
together in public so you absolutely
should go with us borrow one of my
outfits and come as a cute geek couple
with your [ __ ] Warren I'm not big on
cosplay don't let life pass you by man
yeah max are you bigger than anything
are you coming to the party or not I I
didn't expect the decision well my night
why the [ __ ] not if I hate it I can
always go back to my room that's the
spirit max after this you'll be ready
for a rave it does sound like fun now I
have to go contemplate my party future
who talks like that max we're gonna have
to have a little little talky to about
how you talk to other people all right
let's look here where's the bat welcome
to Black Hill no it's black well thank
you very much max that's me and the
girls was right about in the corner damn
it
gu okay I can rewind now cool so the
girls should be here showers
nailed it yeah oh she's gonna be pissed
now isn't she
hey Kate hey you're not it you're not
angry
ah hey Kate sorry about yesterday yeah
I'm sorry you didn't do anything to help
but you're just like everybody else here
that was yesterday
Jesus it's not true I wanted to help but
but whatever it's done by the way max do
you still have my copy of the October
country oh yes of course
it's great so far I didn't realize
Bradbury was such a poet can you please
bring it back to my room this morning I
just need to take some notes for class
absolutely I'll bring it by later why
every time girls talk to each other it
seems like they are trying to it's so
passive-aggressive let's shower it with
our clothes on because of video games or
night I guess I don't [ __ ] you know
what's so weird with water like
showering a Barbie doll or some [ __ ] I
mean I know it's part of the game Sal or
whatever oh god what's she gonna do
what's up Kate it's cool that's it that
video of you clubbing didn't look like
homework
she's mean clapping Victoria that wasn't
me oh my god write him again
don't be shy I think it's awesome you
set a tongue record on video and we're
going to be sorry someday Oh boohoo I'm
sorry you're a viral [ __ ] I'm sure she
had fun looks like it I know Nathan
hooked her up and you know he has the
good [ __ ] preach it sister
why are they so meeting I still have got
him paint all over my face max selfie
thought she was a badass taking that
picture I should have beat her down yeah
that was so uncool she's jealous because
mark mr. Jefferson knows I'm going to
win the everyday heroes contest
he thinks max is a joke don't be don't
listen to her Maxime ooh who seen the
shower she's a weirdo with that dumb
camera I hate that I'm so quirky crap
anyway let's leave the link to Kate's
video so everybody gets a chance to see
her in action you are such an evil
[ __ ] I love it
[ __ ] in here when he here when he here
she writes really fast isn't she what
but that was she put on the same clothes
but those clothes are dirty max we're
gonna have to have a talk about your
hygiene I'm gonna get dressed and go
give that Kate's book but we have to
look what they wrote is that the link to
Kate's video damn Victoria is so [ __ ]
mean she she bought a domain just to
upload a video [ __ ] please you can just
upload after you do even if I can stop
one person from watching it it's worth
it your action get out consequences yes
we did something good today Brea's stand
apt to bullies alright what's I guess
we're gonna have to get the book put it
on her desk oh yeah and then we have
that out alright let's do that
someone went through our shed no [ __ ]
way
this is not why I came to Blackwell and
I still have to clean all this crap up
after I find Kate's book crappy artist
filthy [ __ ]
Victoria of course that's what I get
from making fun of her [ __ ] alright
well let's just get this stupid book and
[ __ ] out my desk is a pigsty but I
know it ain't there you know where is it
then and nothing here doing you goddamn
it in no book here losing my patience
maybe I'll just put on a shirt and jeans
hey Einstein had the same exact suit for
every day of the week and he couldn't
even remind time j21 maximu now where is
that book man this could almost be art
if it wasn't so [ __ ] sick and
disturbed
what's wrong with sick and disturbed hey
hey hey sorry I can't find the book
where is it
I searched here my desk is a pigsty but
my poor Donnie Darko how could anybody
want a break cute little Jake Gyllenhaal
I agree what's it maybe now we can find
the baby yeah I do love a clean room
very zen except for that bull shaker
feeding and except it's not clean at all
max so typical max but where is the
[ __ ] book my even supposed to find it
mmm I don't know
oh here's something
Merryn it no of course she just spilled
soda on Kate's book benefit it goes fast
Kate needs a book and I don't want to
add to our list of problems well how
about you don't put it back um what do
you do
hairdryer Oh rewind for God we can
control time all right let's do that
again and drink the soda first begone
foul soft drink I don't know how you
sneaky book your mind
why don't I rewind now I can finally
take this back to Kate before I'm late
record my if I have to worry about being
late anymore I do have all the time in
the world now that is it my turn record
my webcam record that she's she's the
one doing this show it to the principal
she gets expelled
she's mean so mean seriously though she
kind of sucks for having superpowers all
right one keep your smart mouth shut
about everything or I'm coming for your
anus
I know where you sleep
oh [ __ ] now I'm getting anonymous
threats it never ends
this has to be from Nathan but it could
be anybody
welcome to Black Hill I forgot her name
[Music]
was a Dean welcome to Black Hill Taylor
is no doubt being led around by Victoria
it's not that one hmm well it's not many
more to check as a Katie's Kate you and
Haley well bang for Jesus that's nice
Kate don't be sad hey hey hey hey hey
Kate
I fixed it from the soda to max why
didn't you do anything
when David harassed me yesterday hey I
thought we were cool I wanted proof I
wanted proof David was in your face I
thought he was different
I'm happy to see if somebody cares Kate
I actually do care so what's the story
with you and David well he's a total
paranoid ass he thinks I'm part of the
vortex Club Yeah right
[Music]
why why does he think that because he
saw the video you know how humiliating
this is for me I know this sucks Kate
but tell me about the video and maybe I
can help
basically I went to one vortex club
party and ended up making it with a
bunch of people and I have no memory of
it doesn't sound like you it doesn't
sound like you I can't see you partying
with Victoria I didn't
you have to tell me more than that what
happened at the party
did you drink I swear to God I had one
sip of red wine and then I drank one
there are you sure are you sure it was
just one set I take a separate Church
and I don't end up on a viral video okay
did somebody drugged you I remember I
remember getting sick and dizzy go on
that Nathan Prescott said he would take
me to the hospital yeah Nathan Prescott
Nathan Prescott oh [ __ ] he was being
nice for a change when he offered to
help me he's the opposite of nice what
next don't you remember I recall is
driving for a long time and I woke up in
a room I thought it was a hospital
because it was so white and bright go on
I'm listening somebody who was talking
to me in a soft voice I thought it was a
doctor until I heard Nathan and felt a
sharp sting in my neck and and and
and he put an even don't remember I
don't know what happened I woke up
outside my dorm room the next day I
didn't have any marks or bruises but I
felt gross so who took the video of you
at the party I have no idea
probably Victoria she was there being
her mean self Jesus Kate I'm sorry this
is serious [ __ ] how do I get a viral
video taken yeah I know it's already
spreading Oh what if my church sees that
I need to know what to do
Kate will figure it out I'll check back
later ok thanks max you can put my book
here near my bag got your book girl I
got you a book girl why are they so mean
girls are so mean they should call that
this game so max can I ask you a
question and please be honest you can
tell me anything I need to find out if
Nathan Prescott helped me or hurt me
after that party well woody what the
[ __ ] do you think should I go to the
police well you need proof first if you
do that they won't believe you you're on
video grabbing it all those guys and
don't use that against you bad but I
know I was drugged that's what you have
to prove not them I'm just telling you
how the cops in school will look at this
the video doesn't exactly back you up
you make me feel so hopeless
oh no no Kate I just don't want you to
get hurt anymore that seems impossible
at this point so that's your answer I
think we should wait there are other
things going on that might help you like
what not right now so I can walk down
the halls with people calling me a viral
[ __ ] thanks back yeah that didn't that
didn't really work out the way I just I
despaired um good job doctor
she didn't like what I had to say but we
need more proof of what happened yeah we
need more proof bertha booth why did she
cover up the mirror if she can't look at
herself no all right fine you know how
to feel too bad does it look like I can
and go back oh my god
all right oh yeah yeah I remember now I
can rewind for two fingers Meredith
come on now what what just happened I
thought the point was that I could go
next food to Wales
see you there how dare she [ __ ] dare
she hate only emojis I love emojis
emojis are my life
alright well I think we picked the right
answer then I don't [ __ ] know let's
go to - no need to go there now okay
let's go oh we never put the door of the
book back oh my oh oh my god Jesus still
sobbing are we
so max can I ask you a question and
please be honest okay okay we could go
back I need to find out it I got it at
police yes you should definitely go to
the police Kate I totally believed every
word you say Nathan Prescott is truly
dangerous bless you max I will go to the
police and also principal Wells with you
is my backup witness they'll have to
take us seriously now backup witness
well I mean I believe here on everything
but we're still just spoiled punk
students to the cops and faculty was I
just she wasn't there to be very careful
here
why careful of what nothing except the
Prescotts are a powerful family I hope
this won't backfire on us that's all
even though that rich bastard has earned
some serious bad karma he'll get it
it seemed like the same [ __ ] thing in
regardless so I don't I don't hang out
now you actually told Kate to go to the
police and the principal after getting a
scary text threat now the police will
definitely drag you into this [ __ ] yeah
what's so bad about that Jesus Christ I
don't know if your friend got drugged I
mean if you think she got drugged I
think you should go to the police and I
don't think that's so [ __ ] weird this
game leaves bad messages and this
kidding I was just being on tumblr side
for once
hey beautiful beautiful game look at it
look at that atmosphere mmm look it's
Tom Hanks my mom I always say life is to
shut up now mind you and your [ __ ]
you gotta appreciate how about pretty a
game is like this it really does so much
for that in my sphere Jesus Christ his
nascent father's medal as you know that
attempts to slander and blackmail my
sound would be met with many lawyers and
legal ramifications you're not the first
student there Blackwell to try this I
hope you're the last consider is this a
final polite work well what did I do
and how does everyone get my number and
how do I own managed to get trapped and
maybe if your son is getting threatened
a lot mind Koch's lawrence what are you
doing here nothing waiting for a call I
mean I already took the call anyway I
wanted to rap about that action
yesterday
viable do it by the way thank you for
stepping in you were pretty badass
Warren I owe you
oh yes you do I got knocked on my ass by
that dick I'm some personal superhero
you're a real everyday hero you stood up
to a bully and it was awesome
even though you left me with said bully
and ha ha ha ha ha she's pretty punk
rock how do you know her just a pirate
an old friend Chloe price we haven't
seen each other in a while I bet you're
glad to see her blast up in that truck
like a rock star which begs the question
why he's Nathan Prescott getting psycho
on you well it's his boxing meal I
busted him in a bathroom yesterday with
a gun I'll give you the story later
principal Wells is taking care of it now
I hope you're [ __ ] weak like that
bizarro snowfall yesterday
speaking of dystopia that driving is
having a seventies Planet of the Apes
marathon
let's go ape yes that's exactly what I
need I love those old-school 8 films
well that was easier than I thought
cool I'll text you the info yay we go in
a date take the pass whoo I finally get
to relive my my experiences and as a
teenage girl is my favorite game ever we
take the buzz where's the buzz David
talking to Nathan cannot be a good thing
this has something to do with Kate or
Rachel
yeah hey
you're gonna listen to music do a lot of
fun
[Music]
oh my god I have a colder
we yes
[Music]
catch somebody
catch some light
[Music]
you're falling asleep what you doing
since ID
somebody
come
I figured to be windy in a place like
this it didn't really translate but they
they make those national waves there's a
blue whale we're here baby it's cool
talk about going back in time the diner
looks exactly the same
I never been in a real yeah I do I have
been at a diner one time actually they
are a lot of fake diamonds in your in
smell of breakfast and sound clanging
silverware makes me feel thirteen again
hey dude you know that girl looks
unpleasant nice bunch crack it thumbnail
why she she told me to be there in 14
she's laughs come on man
drew want everything
[Music]
let's change to a song then let's get a
banjo tune that is what I'm talking
about
all right should be good we should we
grab a seat
[Music]
hey you want some coffee there she is
lovely young woman how are you doing
Matt hi choice how does she know nice to
see you you look the same
hmm like I'm still a waitress at two
whales after all these years
no like you so much pretty nice save kid
you're still smart but not that smart
now you get busted for smoking pot I
heard the whole sordid story from David
I'm sorry this was how you had to meet
him he's a good man no matter what Chloe
says yeah I'm sure I don't even smoke
wait ever it was almost an accident
he's very stupid I'm sorry what
surprised me fierce I was hoping you
could be a good influence in her life
now I will be promise I know things were
hard for you and Chloe I feel bad I
didn't call now my folks are in Seattle
and I'm all a little bit black oh it's
my karma you did the right thing you
move forward with your life I did after
William passed on Chloe Chloe chose to
stay angry anyway I hope we see more of
you Chloe needs an old friend again
Joyce I am so sorry about William
they have great memories of him I'm glad
max that was his gift to us wonderful
memories even if Chloe doesn't
understand yet Chloe understands she
just needs time I know that sucks for
you oh she hit all the phases expulsion
running away drugs bad boys tattoos
piercings blue hair stepfather
I see why I mean do you he's not as much
of a hard-ass as you think no I think he
is but you did tell him you had a joint
right you took that responsibility I did
and I am sorry I don't want Chloe and
any more trouble or me nobody's in
trouble over a doobie max and I admire
that you took the heat for Chloe huh
like a great friend but Chloe does push
David and it's not fair he paid his dues
in a war he does care about her along
with all the students at blackwell I get
it Joyce I know Chloe still likes to
stir things up yeah she does provoke
people especially David I just want us
to be a family soon I guess it's all
about time I think you're right choice
so now let's get down to the
nitty-gritty what do you want to eat um
I would like some deer deer meat a
Belgian waffle the last good Belgian
waffle I had was here when I was 13
years old so bring it on now finish your
coffee okay don't tempt don't tell me
what to okay
one Belgian waffle for The Hungry Girl
pronto the lighthouse looks so
mysterious I wish I could stay in this
moment forever I guess I actually can
now yeah but then it wouldn't be a
moment well that was deep Jesus hey hey
I did some beer and bacon before you
know beer it looks like you had plenty
stick with the bacon I was drink the
coffee then I guess how dare you change
my band your music
[ __ ] [ __ ] this is like fourth
dimensional deja vu I keep going back in
time know what kind of dive is this the
only opinions changed on the menu on a
crisis
okay
in common nerd graffiti Warren must have
been here I can hear your stomach
rumbling from here man oh my god she's
scared me you'll love this
what is this I'm drooling like a baby
still can't believe your woman when I
look at pictures of Chloe uh speaking of
the devil
hey - what the [ __ ] back together again
and Chloe looking for a free meal put
your whole damn College Fund on your tab
I'm treating Chloe for breakfast
are you atoning for yesterday oh god mom
please do not give max any [ __ ] for that
she apologized I know she did Max is a
good girl but woman she's 18 now too old
to get lectures from you or Sergeant
Pepper call him David if you don't want
to be lection you only get one damn
slice of bacon a day only one ma'am
you're showing fears you kind of still
the same another reason to blow this
town what is this [ __ ] on the jukebox
[Music]
now that that's out of the way
let's talk about your superpower I don't
care what explanation and I can't
explain why I saw that crazy [ __ ]
tornado come on that's the dream
I want proof you can rewind time yeah
that makes sense this is all happening
so fast
we'll start slow right here now I can
tell you every single thing you have in
your pocket you have x-ray vision dude I
don't even know what's in my pocket let
me see
okay max impress me well I didn't get to
see I don't know do you have some kind
of power or not okay psychic girl let me
show you what's actually in my phone
yeah I need to see first you [ __ ]
idiot
that was beyond epic fail even make me
want to believe you
okay what do we get okay max study every
item carefully and don't forget anything
a panda key secrets
[Music]
okay warning ticket
let's tell me everything what just
happened what did happen
what is going well you had some
pocketing it a parking ticket you know
me well but what is the exact time I was
busted yeah yeah jam eight eleven ten
man that is so oh ok psychic girl let me
show you what's actually in my pockets
my god so she make it so [ __ ] hard
for me I would believe that I'll be like
what how did she actually that was
beyond epic fail you even made me want
to believe you
alright fine okay max study every item
carefully and don't forget anything
okay panicky um there's seven cigarettes
right there is
okay so six cents and four quarters said
it no six cents three quarters and one
five cents and left
10:34 say Francoist okay we got a breast
I hope that bug happens again it's
[ __ ] beautiful
[Music]
[Laughter]
alright Bryce I'm gonna take a break
there if you want to watch the continued
it's gonna be up right now if you go to
PewDiePie calm or if you have the Peter
PI app so just go there check it out and
I'll see you there alright thank you for
watching and thank you for leaving a
like and I'll see you in the next one